when I see this picture I can't help but
think of
as I've seen over the years all
throughout my life usually they were
pictures that I saw on brochures for
nonprofits or saved the children with
some sort of requests of me and some
sort of message about this person being
in trouble and there's a you know she's
it's like a Mona Lisa smile there right
she's a little bit smiling but there's a
sadness in her eyes look I don't know
the pictures that I've seen that come to
mind when I see this are ones that
conjure emotions of pity of urgency of
guilt of this frantic oh my gosh I need
to do something because this is a real
person apparently or so I'm told and she
has you know I'm being told a story
about her but she represents so many
others so the motions that have come up
for me
often when I've seen a picture like this
like you can see someone bending in the
background working right like what I've
seen this have been to be honest if you
can categorize emotions and yes I took
touchy-feely no you're not supposed to
do this but whatever this make their
nature or synthetic their happy sad
they're over here there oh what do we do
now
I feel a nervousness in the tension
right so I go back to my other picture
well no let's do both of them so what if
then you zoom out a little bit and you
see this is the picture there's a lot
more going on there you get context you
get color and you see this woman in a
scene that tells you a whole lot more
about what she might be doing with her
day or at least her hour when this was
taken and for me when I see this those
negative emotions aren't so much there
that they're different emotions that
come up there's curiosity there's
respect that looks like how hot oh the
heavy thing to hold on maybe she carried
it there and I'm guessing but the things
that I guess are not things that make me
feel pity and not things that make me
feel sad and make me feel kind of
curious and sort of intrigued and I want
to know who she is and I want to
understand what's going on there
and I have a lot of other questions for
her when I see this picture surrounded
by the information that is provided on
Kiva this is a you know she's assumed
that she's a borrower on her site when I
see her in that context with that frame
again
it's even more of what happened the last
time it's more of whoa this is an
entrepreneur I'm calling her not for
have a name with her she has her own
name and it's up there it's not just a
nameless face she lives in a particular
place she has a business name and she
has a nickname
Lizzy right not Elizabeth Lizzie she
needs $900 it's a lot of money to me
even but it's it's certainly a lot of
money to her she has plans she has a
story she is the emotions that I get
when I see that are ones that are very
different from the from the ones that I
had in other pictures and growing up
over the years you know spy channel
sponsored children - it was involved
with a lot of nonprofits where the
messages feel bad and therefore act
right this is a different feeling for me
so this is it's 20 I start my taxes way
and I usually end in this way the sort
of end game for me and we can talk all
the whole hour about Kiva and how we've
created this new product and this new
flow of capital zero just step to
microfinance institution that allows
them you know to build their capacity
and do more of what they do and how that
we can talk about the economy and the
interest rates there and we can talk
about keifa's revenue model and how
we're sustainable nonprofit we talk
about all the numbers and all the other
things to be honest with you I feel I
feel a little bit like not not a poser
but like yes I can't have Business
School but the thing that I really care
about are our people and the numbers are
really interesting but they're not
really what makes my heart sing and
they're not what I think is really the
end game to change what I think is what
I hope for with Kiva is yeah it's
awesome when money goes back and forth
but if Jennifer's two sons can start to
have impressions and images of people in
this frame in this context that the
scope is so different than I had growing
up and if they can start to just assume
better things more positive things
assume that there is more possibility
for this person's life then I was told
or than I received that information
when I was growing up if they can do
that I think that's what changes the
world when people think of each other
differently and really deep down in
their gut believed because of a lifetime
of getting data in they really deep down
believe that more as possible for this
person or that group of people that we
saw before
that's when awesome things start to
happen everything else is just sort of
logistics in my mind it's not that
difficult like the other stuff is fun
interesting and nice and a little
intellectual exercise but none of that
happens unless and until you really
believe and think differently about this
human being right so that's sort of the
that's that's like the grand finale of
my talk right so that's what I would say
at the end usually I wanted to say that
up now because we're talking about
stories and framing and all of that so
my story back to this one so same with
this group when you see them like this
you can think all these different things
and you see them like this you see their
names you see what they need you see
what they're doing um
you learned that will keep that I grew
to as an average Kenyan woman she's 46
she has three children she has one
orphan child of her late brother there's
so much in those two sentences and by
the way we don't we don't train really
any of our field partners to write in a
particular way we just let them tell the
story as best they can as close as they
can to what the entrepreneurs themselves
themselves would say anyway so I'm gonna
tell you my story to keep because yeah
that's my story and you can hear my own
personal story and I think that'll tell
you a lot about what Kiva is and why it
started and why we do what we do and the
way that we do it so like I said growing
up I'd all these experiences that
exposed me to poverty relative poverty
abject poverty the first real thing and
the way I talked about possibility just
now um a lot of the most important
moments in my life were times when what
I thought was possible changed and
either
I chose to change those walls or
something came crashing in and blew one
of the walls out and said no no you're
wrong it's this or it's this or
something so in high school I went with
a church group to Haiti and I had heard
about poverty I did my child sponsorship
and all that good stuff I read the
newspaper girls like I I knew there's
poverty out there but going to Haiti and
Mead
people that were my age I'm a senior in
high school you know what you know we're
all like I seniors in high school in a
certain way we look at the world in a
certain I thought my world was this big
to meet other people my age who spent
their whole days working so that they
could eat and that was it that was the
point of their days that was why they
were getting up and doing what they were
doing every day was really hard for me
to understand and it was sort of a
negative possibility sort of changer for
me I thought wow I didn't realize that
was possible I didn't really fully
realize that so I sort of went back home
and a few weeks later its senior prom
and I'm I'm you know in my dress and
this like limo going to senior problems
of senior high school and thinking wait
a minute so that was not a different
world that was one plane flight away how
is this possible
how is it possible that this is my life
but I know now people who have a very
very different life than me and I'm
going off and spending my evening just
having fun and they're maybe they worked
hard enough today and things worked out
enough for them to be able to eat like
how is this possible
so I started to have certain tastes
crisis of I don't understand I'm angry
I'm upset I'm afraid I did I didn't know
how to put all that together and I
didn't even know if it was okay to like
have fun at senior prom or if I should
go do something not you know at every
waking hour to try to help these people
that I met now and knew and they had
names and faces so that was like moment
number one for me
another moment was them then I went to
school and I said philosophy and poetry
and political science and never business
because I thought why would I say
business I want to help people what does
that have to do with anything so I
thought philosophy would teach me how to
think about ideas differently and it
certainly didn't it was a place it was
another possibility expanding sort of
experience for me I mean you go to you
go into class and you start questioning
things that are so fundamental and so
you know crazy good question like how do
we really know the walls behind us when
we when we turn around I mean you
question the basics and you question
what's possible and how you know what
you know and all that good stuff and I
loved that and I I wanted to learn how
to ask the best questions I studied
political science because I thought oh I
think who's making the rules out there
again Business Network
I mind I thought well governments must
be making the rules they're not doing a
very good job because look what's
happening in Haiti for example I want to
figure out these rules and fix them it's
excited political fight
I said poetry just because it was
beautiful and I loved it those are my
three things um then in my junior year I
went on semester at sea has anyone heard
of this program okay
so awesome is anyone gone you semester
at sea so basically you get on this ship
and you go around the world and it's
like the world also an ultimate field
trip you visit like 13 countries and
before you get there you study about
them and anyway it's phenomenal and in
as much as Haiti sort of gave me did
this to what I thought was possible in
the world sure he gave me a spectrum of
whoa people have very different lives
than I do and I think I'm here on the
spectrum like I've been given everything
I could possibly think of and so many
people have so much less Wow in as much
as Haiti gave me that spectrum semester
it's easier to blue that out and made it
multi-dimensional I still felt like I
almost always won out on being lucky and
blessed but it there was so much out
there and sort of expanded the way I saw
the world it was also a chance for me to
be uncomfortable I felt part part of my
frustration was I didn't feel deserving
I didn't know why I'd been given this
really comfortable life and I wanted to
feel uncomfortable I couldn't think of
anything I'd really failed at when I
tried I was always um in high school in
college I was always class or student
body president every year and I always
felt like I'm this little stamp approval
to like say but I thought in my opinions
matters like I felt like my life was
perfect and I wanted to feel
uncomfortable but so I didn't know what
to do and on semester see there's a
funny tradition where when you cross the
equator for the first time you shave
your head so we're gonna blow by that
let's do my head and I decided I'm gonna
be uncomfortable I'm gonna make myself
experience discomfort and so I shaved my
head and I like tried to do things
differently as I could for that time on
semester to get into any like extra
activities I I lived life very
differently for a little while and it
was really good for me I learned a lot
about patience and vanity and all sorts
of stuff but I was questioning who am I
in the world what's my story do I feel
okay about my story and what does it
mean everyone else out there so anyway
it's okay this will pick up a story so
this is a few years out of school so I
graduate I don't really know what to do
I think
this random white middle-class girl from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania that kind of
knows French and likes writing like what
do i what are my skills I don't know but
I knew I was interested in international
development but again nonprofit
international development what kind of
focus is that like okay so they're all
they're both defined by what they're not
so I didn't know how to proceed and I I
actually am it's funny cuz you know this
is cool you talk about like rational
consumer behavior and markets and all
these things and I don't think a lot of
my life decisions have been that
rational I fell in love and I moved to
California right after graduation and I
moved on to Sand Hill Road didn't have a
bike or a job or a car I walked across
campus in my debut and the Stanford
Business School was day two in
California ever for me and I handed my
resume out and got a job as a temporary
administrative assistant in the PNP for
someone on medical leave and I I was a
secretary here for a little while and I
ended up staying for three years here as
staff now what was great about this was
I just took the job sanity to pay my
rent and it sounded kind of interesting
but what was great was my job involved
pretty quickly and I got to do other
things like the first global
philanthropy forum that was awesome and
more or less imagine being here not
having to do the coursework for getting
to sit in and like classes and go to
speakers at lunchtime and it you know
5:15 in Bishop and anytime there was
something awesome you get to go listen
in how great is that
so I spent three years getting to do
that and in fact planning some the
events and have any acute an excuse to
talk to amazing thought leaders so that
just you can imagine again having no
exposure to business up until that point
it was like wow this is fascinating time
value of money what if this is who knew
like it was a new language new
vocabulary everything was just blowing
my mind so one of those people that I
heard speak about two and a half years
in was dr. Muhammad Yunus this guy that
I thought it made me heard about before
this was two three years before you
moved in the Nobel Peace Prize for his
work pioneering microfinance with
Grameen Bank but basically he came to
campus it was like an S 152 it was a
last minute thing I went and I sat on
the floor was super casual and basically
this man came in
and I love this is the perfect thing for
this class he told his story and the way
he tells his story is really about one
day I thought this and I did this you
know I walked across the across town
into a village I taught at this lovely
University but I I wanted to really see
what poverty was like he isn't an
economics professor and he he sits down
and talks to people who are stuck in
this cycle of lending are very poor he
listens to them he hears what they need
he reaches in his pocket and lens like
24 dollars total and a whole village has
helped it's this fairytale amazing
magical story and it's really truly his
story and it's a story about how he did
very things that seemed so accessible
and so doable so I'm sitting there just
like lightning bolt shooting through my
system like made sense to my head and
they touched my heart the way he talked
this was huge the way he talked about
the people they didn't met that were in
poverty was different than anything I'd
ever heard before
it was he talked about them with dignity
and mutual respect his people who were
already working hard even though they
were very poor and it was this system
that was keeping them poor not them not
laziness about all these other things
but unfortunately sometimes we hear and
I loved it and I thought I really I want
to go do that and I decided I wanted to
go do something like what he did and I
wanted to learn about microfinance and I
thought those are my skills I can sit
and talk to people of listen and I can
reach in my pocket lend $25 I could do
that I want to go do that so a few
months later I'd quit my job here and I
went to East Africa with a nonprofit
called Village Enterprise Fund and they
do 100 dollar grants to entrepreneurs
who for various reasons aren't yet ready
for a loan or there's no one else
serving them can they live in an
incredibly remote area and their other
parts too but that's that's just of it
anyway I go to East Africa at this point
in my life had been married for six
months to the boy that I fell in love
with and moved out here for three or
three and a half four years later so
we're married to Clinton and I leave for
this three-month
dream job to go from village to village
to village as a new village every two to
three days as by myself but met up with
volunteers along the way and interviewed
entrepreneurs who'd receive this hundred
it was the coolest three months of my
life it was the best
I would sit down with the goat herder
and listen for an hour to about you know
did they receive the money what did they
used it for what was the story of their
business how did they use that $100 did
how did their lives change and I started
patch together this standard of living
survey that included questions like you
know before and after the business could
you can you afford to put sugar in your
teeth do you sleep on a mattress or read
mat do you have a blanket to stay warm
at night does your family own mosquito
nets how many meals do you eat a day is
it and often it would be to milk tea in
the morning and something you know maybe
beans and rice or something later in the
day how many times a week or a year do
you eat protein there are these details
of their life to try to understand where
they were and how they were choosing to
improve their lives as things went well
with their businesses but just like they
gave me the smokes they were so
interesting so beautiful and things came
out out of left field that I would have
never expected about how they had chosen
to change their lives so for example one
family said oh well as my business
improved I send my I sent my my first
two children to school and they've never
been before but my you know ten year old
has a disability and needs needed a
wheelchair so it took another two years
for us to save up for a wheelchair and
then she was able to go to school too or
you know our kids were our kids and we
sent some of them to school but you know
we really wanted we wanted a lock in our
door because we wanted to feel secure or
we really thought the best thing was for
us to eat better because we were getting
thin and losing weight and getting sick
or the ways that they had chosen in
there of their own volition to change
their lives we're all just fascinating
and not every story that I heard was a
success story many of them had their
flaws I mean not all the business six
succeeded sometimes the businesses were
going well but then someone got sick and
it was do you buy more inventory for
your business did you get the malaria
medicine medicine so your child doesn't
die and they would she's letter and
sometimes they would choose the former
it just like every day was just a whole
range of emotions for me and I became
obsessed with these stories um I started
in the evenings you know I'd be me
sitting and hut somewhere with candle
I'm like what do you do in the evenings
you don't know anybody you don't see ya
so you'd hang out with family as much to
kid but then before I'd go to bed I
would just write down everything I could
remember of these stories that wasn't
even on the surveys and when I would get
to an internet cafe every once in a
while it would send me stories to my
friends and family on email once and I
would also be able to call and say oh my
gosh
check it out talk to my new friend the
seamstress in true Uganda she's so
awesome and I didn't vote over and it's
a little bit of a she talked to my mom
or Matt or it was so fun so anyway you
got it I'm like obsessed with these
stories and the other thing was these
stories were as dr. Yunus too described
there were stories of dignity and hope
they were different it was not what I
had expected exactly yes people were
suffering yes there was need but there
were stories of triumph and story of
effort and stories of people doing
extraordinary things with this little
bit of money and going above and beyond
and working hard and having success they
were these beautiful hopeful intriguing
business stories so when I was when I
was sharing these with friends and
family and at that time Matt I was there
for three months he came over for like
the middle two and a half three weeks of
my trip and he too was like whoa this is
different than I thought these are not
the stories I expected to hear these are
not the people I expected to meet this
is so cool we started to want to share
these so I mean I'm gonna start to
fast-forward really quickly so get ready
who's ready to share them with friends
and family friends and family cut one
off would respond with Wow
josepho Nyong'o the goat herder in
uganda sounds amazing
um you know what's he gonna do next are
you gonna go see in the gun if you do
give him hundred dollars from me or lend
them two hundred dollars from me or
whatever people wanted to be engaged in
specific ways they didn't say wow what a
nice story I will write my check now to
this big nonprofit and that's that and
in my friends and family no one's a big
high net worth individual they're like
big donor everyone I was like maybe 25
50 bucks hundred at a time that they can
donate and it's scattered and a lot of
it goes to church a lot of it goes to
like a Girl Scout cookie pit I mean it's
random and people only have a little
time to get so anyway even if they would
have given their money here and no one
was socially responsible investing
you're kidding me no one even knew what
that was so no one does that that I know
really it's really um are very few
people but at the time that wasn't an
option so sort of like what would they
do would they donate money no one really
wanted to do that
and even if they would have what a
boring experience maybe you get a
thank-you letter maybe and that's that
are you gonna call it Christmas anyway
wasn't fun and the big aha moment spring
of o4 as I'm hearing all these stories
ended up interviewing about 150
entrepreneurs was Wow these stories
should be chair should be shared and in
fact if more people knew these stories
two things would happen we would see
each other differently which is huge and
people would be motivated to act maybe
maybe they wouldn't but I know I felt
motivate act from a very different place
than I'd ever felt before and I thought
that was a wonderful thing so the task
became how do we share these stories and
then the idea of lending seemed just
appropriate because it was direct and
real that was what people needed Ness
not a donation these were business
people they didn't need a handout they
needed just this loan microfinance kind
of the name of the game to do the next
part of the business so Springer
Beaufort had had this idea to do this
very small specific thing spring of oh
five we had built a website I went back
to Uganda handed a camera to our buddy
Moses and said hey let's go visit we had
seven entrepreneurs that we've been in
touch with for the whole year on email
and staff through Moses yep oh so this
is funny at the time
since I was working in East Africa I was
learning Swahili and was kind of
obsessed with the language and this
esoteric random dictionary online
apparently it means unity I've yet to
meet a native East African endowed with
word so it's kind of like the Chevy Nova
waiting to happen maybe but luckily it
also means nice and finished and it
means um it's like a Native American
word for a gathering place the idea was
unity right that was our effort
I would like it when you turn on the
phone conversation that's so funny yeah
that would be fun yeah okay
and I am I want to get to questions of
answer excited there's a lot I've
basically loved when it's a dialogue so
um what do I have next here yeah this
was that was obvious this is a slide
that's two months old but yeah yeah yeah
so I'd like to just sort of open it up
any other things that kind of strength
about the story so far like how you got
how you're reacting what do you think is
differentiated it's hard to tell people
stories away
like they're talking from their own
culture or philosophy to put people from
a different place in the world in their
own
and were able to really zero in on
people
stories and you know as as you did
down two
one of the most important things that
you come from away from this classic
speaking small so again remember next to
what do you want to call your your King
on I feel and I talk about telling tell
stories or the condition and so again
one of the goals the individual so later
wrote that Casablanca screen plan on
sending you home because of my
screenplay encourage you to get together
with your cohort and watch casablanca
and one of the things there is not only
each micro threads or micro lines and
micro stories within the larger whole
Casablanca
but it's the exact emotional mapping so
what you can do as you're watching
Casablanca is you can literally just
take some sort of like I feel like this
and if you just draw that as you're
watching Casablanca it will destroy the
viewing experience but he will a much
finer sense of what the emotional arc
was in what you know what actually
happened during that time and I'll do
five minutes just before we go into the
full-on question answer just to say
here's out where it's a little while I
can do that real quick
you were looking for your next step to
at the beginning but
whatever is fueling it people get people
and 9008 you'll like this 90% of people
keep their money in the system
so people we like it's a hugely loyal
group people real and real and real and
and add to their portfolios and it turns
out he never got this - it turns out the
loan we didn't know this at the
beginning it's a very sticky tool it's a
very good tool for connectivity because
if I give you something even if you're
like great at giving updates and stuff
it's only so relevant we all know that
like my $25 a year ago probably still
isn't having that same look fresh impact
as it was like it's great and there's
other secondary and tertiary effects but
like really but if it's alone and you
keep getting your dollar 25 back every
month or something it's a very different
feel
so
it struck me how passionate you are
about it I mean here you are you were
married for six months then you go to
East Africa and they're just like
village to village to village but you're
still passionate about you're so excited
about it as opposed to being you know
was really tough to you didn't mention
at all like it was really hard to do
that it was hard like not to see my
husband it was hard to be to go to all
these different villages you're talking
about passion your and how that passion
kind of moved on to your friends and you
talked to your friends on the phone
and they all want to send money money
pumpkin some way I think that it's kind
of how passionate villains it actually
makes me makes me passionate about it
the fact you're so passionate so cool
okay well they I mean that's that's a
whole other class right
but yes good I'll do it
hmm yeah it's you know I forgot about
that part too like that wasn't my sin I
loved it and I remember asking right I'm
like Brian these he's my boss and like
amazing mentor the guy that started your
verse Asian breath what if I like you
let me like come back and just spend
some time writing these out like making
awesome case studies and take pictures
and like these would be really cool to
share things like sure whatever and that
yeah well I didn't have anything to do
with like analyzing the data I'm like it
was all her nice expel ass Excel
spreadsheet but I didn't I didn't really
like it wasn't that exciting probably
quite emotional store is that many
probably got into gee I don't know
because restored so when they know you
breathe responses if you have a personal
personal stories that define to you and
as you start to think about those
stories and how they infect the
organizations that will be creating the
more power you will have
where they are and it's always inspiring
sometimes distancing like you just think
about it you know or if you are smart
enough it's actually really appreciate
you that you didn't try to be the expert
or say you know everything and I think
bringing it Muhammad Yunus was great
than you aspire to you but he himself
isn't me because he is such an expert in
what he does yeah and actually found it
very like personalize it that you're
like I'm not here to tell you like this
everything is perfect or that I'm you
know exactly I do I know I tried to be a
connecting point and I thought it was
really not condescending about money you
mentioned your own family there weren't
these because sometimes people who are
saying it has been fantastic give a lot
more money so we would be me even though
you're inspired you're like yeah I don't
have two thousand dollars or something
like that what they might be implying
kind of their backstory so I like that
you brought the cooler
well it's funny cuz when you said the
only thing here ago only thing people
remember about my classes like the phone
thing but you know it's a joke like I
actually think that happens where I
could even tell all you could read the
same information that maybe you'd see on
this business profile you know from
before but if you also include some of
the other details like you know maybe
the only thing like I have this neighbor
I've never met that has this bizarre
sculpture in the yard all I know about
them is they have bit bizarre sculptures
and sometimes the details that we threw
out there for better for sometimes like
one really surprising one or something
will stick and everything else sorta
gets lost I think it's very good to be
very careful because like in that one
business profile Ted she was one orphan
child from her brother I mean could talk
just about that could have talked about
a lot of different things that probably
wouldn't stuck and it would have
overshadowed other details gonna be very
careful what you reveal and what you
don't
further cool
thinking about these ideas and how they
affect your causes I'm keeping even
about the wall of measurement so for
example Jessica mentioned this she just
just broke out she's just developed a
little questionnaire and started
developing I'd like to keep an eye on
any opportunities you have to measure
that one individual and then she brought
back out some experimental information
provided context around and if you in
your videos or your photographs whatever
you do this week to engage others in
your cause if you keep an eye on
experimentation so you create two
conditions one with photographs just a
face
with the context or the lot sort of one
of you did with the Twitter you know you
sharpen the word give me one word
concrete so play with experimentation
and make sure you so I can't not tell
the 10-second story of this guy this guy
and it kills me because over the years I
have free on his name it was five years
ago I gotta like go back and figure it
out
contacts and real and that's the whole
point but he had a second grade
education second to not seven second and
he had three wives living in Tanzania
had a 100 or grant supported thirty five
people
I'm his fishery fishing business with a
one hundred Allah grant where all I did
was get new nets that um didn't have as
many holes you know bigger holes and it
to catch fish in this lake they had I
think it was four maybe five chickens or
turkeys running around they of course
gave me because I'd visited them for two
hours they wanted to thank me for coming
to visit them and gave me one of their
turkeys which I reqif did like you know
I didn't that's all that's what that's
how I justified they don't offend them
and tonight um it was one of the best I
mean these were like the best days of my
life and up into that point um I could
talk for an hour just about this family
so and they're 150 of those that I got
to hear those stories over three months
so okay so fast forward it took a year
in another I'm speaking in Rick Aubrey's
class tomorrow and I could tell you
where the nuts and bolts is like doing
the Entrepreneurship thing and like what
we did and funding and all that stuff
but it's fast forward spring go for we
have the idea research for a year um I
applied to the dispiay
assay was on poetry and like wrote poems
and said them my most important matters
mean why thing was finding your voice
that's high that's what I did um I got a
GC I knew I was coming in Falvo five
spring of oh five we did like a bait
around finally where we so it's a year
later we did seven businesses it what
they needed a total three thousand bucks
we
her wedding list and said what do you
guys think we don't know if it's legal
yet because we spent a year banging our
heads against the wall saying is this
legal is this legal no one would we
everyone is like I don't know people
would physically back away from us in
the room if we would talk gonna be like
yeah I don't know it's gonna be really
hard and a lot really hard and really
dangerous you know you might you should
call the SEC like they were just throw
terabyte of this because we would this
was so interesting to actually story
related stuff we would say we want to
lend three thousand dollars to these
seven people here are their names and
Tharoor are uganda you know we want to
do this can we do this how do we do this
and they heard international
peer-to-peer lending all over that's
scary
it would they heard this big thing we'd
say no no no no we just must start by
doing this how do we do this but they
would extrapolate it out and here are
bigger things very interesting
communication lesson for us and also
like the language of innovation we were
talking we would talk for an hour and
say our idea and that people ask
questions in at the end they'd say well
this is great you know where do I donate
or they would say you're crazy this
dangerous or whatever else we would say
we are not donating we are lending so
it's interesting you have a new product
new idea never said donate we never said
invest we didn't even allow people to
donate on the site the first year and a
half because people were so confused by
this we would only say loan but people
would hear something different that was
fascinating
lots of stuff okay so the first so we
debate around we in October fo 5 I'm
here like trying to survive accounting
class and all the core stuff we decide
six months into our beta round we
decided to success we take the route
paid off the site we call everybody
Moses cuz no organization would work
with us at this point because we who
were we they didn't they thought it was
a silly idea and really time-consuming
and wouldn't work so we and called our
buddy Moses again and said hey you want
to post another 1215 businesses he said
sure we write a press release about our
seven businesses that we funded and
we're like we are so official this is
great it's October 5 November ngo5 the
blogosphere somehow picks up like a
month later picks up when this little
press release that our friend from like
a Bible study wrote and we just put on
their site totally random and 300 blogs
wrote about us in November of oh five
including two the three white biggest
blogs in that time boy boy and DailyKos
they're still big so suddenly one day
not just our little friends and family
like coming to the site but a million
people read about Kiva and all flood at
the site we tens of thousands people
coming that's working at Tebow during
his full time job I'm here we're just
doing this on nights and weekends and
suddenly all these people are coming
we're like what the heck is going on
because I didn't know the blogosphere
didn't read any blogs suddenly at least
people are coming so anyway over the
next month other media picked up January
two months later like The Wall Street
Journal included us in an article with
Grameen Bank Waco credit some other a
big leader in like Kiva this is insane
we funded like 20 businesses we don't
deserve to be in this but basically the
impression that people got because of
the buzz in the blogosphere and more and
more blogs wrote and these traditional
media things were picking up we seemed
more real than we were we still weren't
even a register organization again just
winging it so Matt and I had this like
come-to-jesus moment or like one of us
has to quit something not quit his job I
almost quit the GSB I'm glad I didn't
but um we sort of got her out together
and started to be real in like spring of
odd six so anyway first year October 5
doe six we did five hundred thousand and
loans that year we were flipping out we
had like five real partners we were
totally excited second year in the GSB
that's where things are in life so
that's first year five hundred thousand
second year was fourteen million third
year close I think it like forty five
today it's at fifty-six million and we
do about a hundred thousand a hundred
thousand dollars or more a day in these
little twenty five dollar bits their
lenders and entrepreneur's in 150
countries worldwide and it's just grown
really fast obviously that's a big
summary but I can touch down on any
other parts you'd like to know the way
it works today is not us calling our
buddy Moses but we have lenders
obviously come inside browse these
profiles the profiles are posted there
by microfinance institutions all over
that go through this big doodle do
diligence and vetting process with them
give them an account on the system
depending on what sort of rating we give
them we developed a rating system if
there are five star and mi5 according to
us maybe they have you know X hundreds
of thousands of dollars size an account
that they can fundraise each month on
our site if their one star partner maybe
it's five thousand every month or ten
thousand every month and we monitor them
and monitor that and it's this huge
we're in them with like 37 different
qualities there's a lot of science
behind it which is fun but basically
they have accounts to post the profiles
they raise money
it goes from lender to Kiva Kiva the MFI
and the five to that specific person
comes back with interest from that
borrower according to the MFI we don't
micromanage we choose only really good
ones that we think are doing fair good
socially you know focus business with
those clients they pay back Kiva just
the principle no interest they keep all
that interest which is why it's valuable
to them they're saving ten fifteen
percent on their cost of debt because
they source it through us it's also
flexible friendly bet from lenders that
like take the default risk all sorts of
other risk and then we pass back the
principle to you the lender so 70% of
our revenue if this interesting comes
from this optional lender fee where
right when you check out we say thanks
so much
all your $25 is going to the seamstress
in Cambodia that you've chosen although
to come back if you know slash as she
repays which almost always happens but
would you help us pay our rent and we
finally after like a year and a half
allowed people start donating and we say
you're lending twenty five would you
donate two dollars and fifty cents when
people are comfortable with that price
point they're all ending twenty five and
seeing that go out the door they're
almost always comfortable with donating
another two fifty or fifty-five or
whatever it is ten percent so seventy
percent of our costs in 2007 were
covered by that and that's just one of
five revenue streams we have float and
even time there are millions of dollars
in our account going back and forth we
get interest on that we do traditional
fundraising there's all there's the
business step to this too and that's fun
but this is the site you go you click
lend you see a group you click on them
you get the profile page like we've seen
this is a huge group kind of an anomaly
if you'd scroll down you'd see lenders
to this group one of the other things we
do on Kiva and I did make like get
slides but I think we should just talk
in like two minutes
uh if you click on a lender profile you
this isn't one of those bare-bones
lender profile pages you'll see my
favorite parts on the site is when it
says island it's the island
change its grammatically not as good but
I loaned Vikas right I went because if
people say why she just says because I
can other people have these they get on
their top box that's awesome and they
say like what they believe in why
they'll end and why they feel privileged
in what they love about Kievan
interacting this way it's very cool if
you're interested in browse those I love
those but basically they have their own
portfolio page to say oh yeah well
here's my story here's Who I am here's
what I'm doing and it's really really
easy our site is not rocket science it's
a very very bones very simple as you can
see and if you look under the hood of
the site it's very funny it's patched
together I mean that designed it you
know the Barrett the first parts of it
at nights a week on nights and weekends
when he was like kind of learning to
code on his own it's not it's scrappy
and I think that's actually part of our
personality and our Sensibility um oh
this is important I wanted to see I'll
get that
journals you can see the journal updates
so the stories keep coming as the money
comes back you get updates with a often
a qualitative little update on hey green
isn't Anthony I guess what's going on
here you can you you can read it and I
think right now we have every one for
every loan you always get the
quantitative little repayment updates
and I think at any given time we're
working hard to make this go up and up
and up but we have these like really
good often their paragraphs and
paragraphs written by fellows we have a
Fellows Program which is basically a
repeat of my dream job from four years
ago where we send people out you
interview 150 businesses and you blog
about them and you check on them and you
do sort of a soft audit and an update
with these stories and they see it
through fresh eyes and they tell other
lenders of what they've seen and who
they've met and what it's like it's
awesome and take pictures so anyway
about 20% of businesses I think right
now that's our stat have at least one of
these qualitative journal entries we
want it to be much more also blending
teams that's a telling story there's a
Stanford GSB team join it join them okay
here's the deal
our mission is to connect people through
lending to alleviate poverty for poverty
alleviation um it's not let's raise them
this one Mike
it's not let's build this huge and
powerful Network exemplifies these other
things are happening indirectly but it's
not war about we've turned down money
when it doesn't allow us to connect
human beings to each other that's how it
started I could spend a lot of time
telling you that's how it started and
that's still the spirit of it today when
we get big corporations saying we want
to pump like ten million dollars through
the Kiva system we're like oh you mean
by allowing your employees to come each
have accounts and you're gonna give them
all the monies give certificates and
they'll have this experience of choosing
entrepreneur and interacting you want to
do that and they're like no no we just
want the money to go through the system
and we'll say no that's okay thank you
though but we can recommend some other
places to put your funds or you can
donate but we're not interested because
it would actually take away from our
mission of connecting human beings to
one another um I did create this other
the other slides for the get stuff so do
want to go there and structure a
conversation that way and then I can
pull up slides if we want cuz I feel
like I should stop there I want to hear
what you're thinking it's already along
yeah um I think the Siamese destroyed
like sensibility or brand I don't know I
kind of like that word lately and I'm
just gonna use it again so that like
sensibility we like if you have you been
to witness witnesses site it's like this
Human Rights site where they basically
like here's what's happening out there
and they just like show it right they
just show whatever it isn't something
very scary er sad or painful and it
means the stories need to be told but um
I think the way we framed the stories
even in the beginning where we're really
they were just so fun to read I mean I
know I'm biased I loved reading them I
think they were just fun to read so even
when you couldn't do anything on the
site blogs are still writing about it
because you could it was this authentic
yeah I mean I think it was the stories
I'm only guessing I don't really know I
think a lot of influential blogs picked
it up out it was it was lucky and then
there started to buzz about it too so I
think the blogs encouraged other blogs
and mostly the other thing is in it was
a sound like it it sounds crazy to say
this no but it's like a really
innovative thing to do lending like you
couldn't do that anywhere online you
could not lend money it was a new new
thing you certainly can lend to another
person like that I mean prosper calm
launched I think November of 5 like they
launched right around the same time that
we had been finished with our beta round
so this was right around that time to so
it was like oh there's this new thing to
do on the internet lending to a person
what's right about it so we were lucky
because prosper is launching there was
press about them we were the
international version of that 2005 was
the year of microfinance um how would
you just win the Nobel Peace Prize in
2006 like there were all these things
that converged where we became this
interesting oh and by the way here's how
you can get involved because this was
the first way that it it was really made
for individuals to actually do something
but I don't know I'm microlending
microfinance micro Michael place which
we started out together wicker place
very good place and we all it's another
again maybe you'll talk around classes
tomorrow
but we we also actually started together
the summer before GSB I was in we were
all working as a group of four and then
we decided it was a great way for us
both to decide who we were and who we
weren't they wanted to securitize the
space we wanted to do personal stories
we thought it was so similar at the time
we lived like three blocks away primal
and Tracey me and Matt we thought we
could do it together and we sort of
realized no no no no here's who we are
news or not but there's that you can
invest for a profit like three percent
over a few years to a microfinance
institution so if there's a spectrum and
I do have a good slide for this there's
a spectrum of giving and lending are
giving and investing and purse
institutional personal you know Kiva's
at the investing slash lending personal
micro places like investing at the
organization level and of course there's
socially responsible investing
opportunities where you invest in like
huger things so
name and they what you talk about
it's really
Wizards of senior you can do 10 years
oh yeah so when I was thinking about the
get stuff my whole like an algae which
is dork even I'm dirty I don't care it I
it was like oh this is like falling in
love like it's all about falling in love
and I think people fell in love with
with Kiva and we wanted it wasn't always
rational it wasn't always because we
were doing things perfectly we're kind
of scrappy throwing things together our
business model in the beginning was
really bumpy but people loved it so
would think about like getting attention
we think about think of hopefully
everyone here's all in love right like
think of when you you get that attention
like I don't know it's not always
rational but there's something that like
draws there's some chemistry that you're
like whoa and then engaging I mean
there's this this this flirtatiousness
this there's something I mean I have my
other sides but it this whole way of
getting attention
I think people they love Kiva and I
don't know
exactly why I mean I think it's I love
the entrepreneurs that I got to meet and
I think as much as you can just make
that introduction I mean we love we love
each other people love each other people
have other people so if you can
introduce them to people that Surprise
them and compel them and intrigue them
they fall in love and they they just
wanted they want to even deal with the
crappy site and they they don't mind
clicking more times than it's like a web
2.0 a kind of best practice to get to it
and they don't mind like patching stuff
together building their own tool because
we didn't pound around to it or and
we're good tech company too but like
people do things in spite of barriers if
they're in love and if they're just like
you're saying they're passionate about
it so I don't know that we should be
followed in a lot of things maybe we
didn't we were ridiculous in our funding
our funding with my student loans and
like we didn't we weren't able to pay
staff at the beginning at least for the
first year right um so we would say oh
we can't pay you but you want to sleep
on her couch and they keep dinner with
us would that help so that worked we
couldn't pay someone to design our logo
we're like oh but this is really our
dream like do we have anything that we
own that you once we gave the designer
of Maxwell guitar like this is how we
did it their game we're not like oh we
did the perfect funding strategy and
what's your angel look like I don't know
what an angel was you kidding no so I
think you like when you have a dream
when you're passion you're in love like
you throw a bunch of stuff out the
window and you just like get it done and
you go for it and you so I don't know
to the person who's giving it to you
right like it's it's just the way they
interact with you and now the
relationship between you is
fundamentally different than any other
utilitarian business exchange based
model that creates it creates time to
create money to get to people to say
like I would like to you to it just like
that and that's you didn't give it to me
or you know it creates a whole different
dynamic
you have this multiplier effect which we
call we had like 17 full-time staff at
this point just focused on that so we
kind of divided up the world and I can
show you not to like push your question
away but it's there's a lot of
information on our website about like
here's what we check on here so how we
qualify here's the vetting process here
all my partners and why they how we rate
them it's all there and it's a lot it's
a it's kind of complicated to talk about
but I can show you send you if you send
me an email say go here and I'll send
you links that sound good
they move some motors Oh such a okay
wait this is great yeah we totally did
meathead fraud only about like four out
of about like how I say about that's
terrible we've had four cases of fraud
out of one hundred and twelve partners
up until now and also at the beginning
we went very quickly from at the
beginning like begging for people to
work with us we actually had two people
just graduating graduating undergrad at
Stanford that are like we think we could
go start an MFI and like Nicaraguan
we're like awesome you can have all your
funding through Kiva like we were just
come one come all let's use it as a big
experiment we'll partner with anybody
right and now we like turn down most
people or most sympathize that come to
work with us so when we did have when we
have had problems we believe in this
radical transparency sort of way of
communicating flenders so when we have
had fraud we tell people like when we
know we tell them what happened we say
we're so sorry you won't get your money
back because someone like ran away with
it or whatever happened but we hope
you'll keep lending and thanks for
hanging in there with us this is hard
work to do we're doing our best we
really appreciate you like doing this
wonderful social experiment with with us
and people write back and say thank you
they say thank you for being honest
thank you for telling us about the fraud
keep it up
hang in there we're totally gonna lend
again like we get thank-you letters
after we say we've had fraud sometimes
like it's wild so let me show you a
screenshot of we and we say if we're
like oh shoot you know when this fellow
visited the business it actually wasn't
the right picture it was someone else
oops we'd say that like we this is an
example of if everything was wrong on
the you know on the page like if a
fellow showed up and they're like what
is this the photo is wrong the amount
was wrong the location was wrong like we
would put it all there and we would tell
people and just say with you in our best
and this doesn't happen a lot so we also
do a good job but when it does we in
just a really honest and that people
seem to really appreciate that because
again think of like turning the old
nonprofit model on its head like
everyone wants to always say
everything's working great and perfectly
and your money all goes there and we
just we say here's the reality and we
don't like oh this is a lot of the
feedback in the beginning like the first
year when we were like asking anybody
who would talk to us hey is this legal
why don't you do this
about this what about this and we'd cold
call the SEC which actually does have
very good customer service which is
surprising we would say are you gonna
arrest us what'll happen
it's just who's doing this right and
people would say well you should really
aggregate risk that's a nice that's a
nice little like best practice sure
aggregating risk is good and investing
but we didn't want to do that we didn't
want us to be this we wanted to be the
connection so you don't aggregate risk
you bet on this person and maybe they
fail and other people would say oh well
you should really let people donate
because they want to tax write-off but
these were people that give tens of
thousands of dollars and want the tax
right now I'm four years would keep my
with all receipts for like I gave my
sweater to Goodwill Oh it's like $13 or
I gave me $25 it never uttered to my
taxes ever
I never made enough money it doesn't
matter and so like if you're really a
donor at a twenty million dollar price
flame you probably don't care about tax
right now so it's interesting because
you'd hear these like logical
common-sense see kind of good ideas
about a feedback about our model but
actually if you really got in the shoes
of that person if I'm gonna donor of $25
I don't care about the tax right now if
I'm you know it was interesting this is
totally not a question I'm still talking
about I'm sorry but it wasn't it's been
interesting to like hear these very good
points made in very rational ways by
logical experts um but to try to do
something different anyway because we
thought no maybe not maybe they don't
know like my friends and family and what
they really want
so did I answer your question though
originally okay awesome
Oh
African women are African women get
funded ten times more quickly than like
Bulgarian men for example people get
that we have this whole talk about
useful regression projects like we you
we know like if there's a kid in the
picture it gets I'll tell you all the
things that it gets funded more quickly
child in the picture the darker the skin
color the more rural the seen the if
there's a visible physical disability
like watch out that thing won't go like
it's it's it's it's it feels weird to
know these things but it's really true
so we know a lot about lender slash
donor behavior in fact let me say this
good question um okay let's take these
so these are all people I've had the
privilege of lending to popcorn seller
in Samoa
um let me do this this guy great butcher
knife gotta said so he's scowling
there's like meat hanging in the
background a lot of our lenders happen
to be very I mean in the beginning at
this point in time they're like very
liberal you can imagine a lot of
Californians maybe being vegetarian or
something like that
they're not exactly turned on by like
this picture right if you if I could
make up a story about this guy in the
beginning who knows what would've come
out of our mouths right so he's kind of
the underdogs like I wanted to lend to
him cuz I know he'd be slower although
the good thing is he's in Afghanistan so
let's go okay well this guy totally
slower fun and he's in a pretty urban
looking scene poverty looks very
different to him being shut out of a
financial institution is a reality for
him because he's a gypsy right of Roma
culture that's unprecedented gypsy but
you know what I mean so he um he had a
real he had a real need it was just as
real as this woman's need Elizabeth's
right but she strikes people so
differently and by the way it's so funny
when you're describing your sons when
like behavior not atypical of like adult
lenders right or with kids in classrooms
often they'll tend towards like fluffy
sheep
pretty animals and the pictures too but
really kids and adults I think often
make very similar behavior similar
decisions what I what we hope is that we
can we talked about which details you
choose to reveal so you can see about
the entrepreneur in that about the field
would it be great if actually you had
like legit market forces that work here
right now every business on the site has
always gotten funded so there's not
competition happening yet because
everyone just gets funded if you are
over the bar right and you're a partner
and you post things accurately um would
it be awesome if you had six potential
borrowers all in you know western Kenya
and everything was the same except
they're out they were served by
different partners and the different
partners would be able to say well we
serve only women well we do we have
lower interest rates we train people for
like a year before we lend to them
whatever it would be it'd be interesting
I'm not saying that are worse but when
if you interesting as people started to
make decisions more on that versus
smiley face can the picture it's our so
it's yeah it's a big responsibility to
know those things and to it's so
tempting to wanna like you know hold off
on posting anymore Kenyan women until
like these poor Bulgarian guys get
funded and it's still a matter of like a
few hours versus a few days like
everything gets funded really fast but
you think this may be a terrific
organization a great success
50 years so no totally totally so we
don't want to be around if people don't
want to do it's like a business says how
can we always guarantee we'll sell sell
our product well people don't want to
buy the parking or we don't want to sell
it so maybe it won't happen I hope it
does I think it will I think will evolve
we're nimble and flexible and act
quickly and we iterate and I think we
have the right values in place to be
able to change with the times can thing
but in terms of factual finances we have
five revenue streams the one was the
optional donation from lenders which I
said that may go down over time with
real ending you know who knows
the other one is float interest as the
money goes back and forth and we do have
like this for-profit part that holds the
lenders money its invested in money
market funds like we have we're good
investors of that 3 and these are
smaller but they're interesting 3 is
breakage on gift certificates
it's kind of high threes breakage on
gift certificates I could talk to more
about that if you want to but it's
basically you never use your gift
certificate we reabsorb it and in that
category is actually unused credit -
we're starting to implement that if it's
sitting there for two years we'll
observe it back if you don't reel in for
it's like normal fundraising which we're
getting better and better at like
getting grants from school and Draper
Richards and whatever individuals and in
five whatsits ago well so we've done
actually real services for businesses so
for example so real actual technically
you know revenue for services so we had
a small business credit card company
come to us and say hey we'd really love
to have our credit cards be used and
have keep people get Kiva credit instead
of get like my airline miles or
something can you help us design that
and they paid us a bunch of money to
design this thing that actually results
in more loans and more everything anyway
everybody wins the other thing is though
we had not even begun to touch like our
debt capital is so good for my thighs
they save like I said 10-15 percent on
average cost of debt through us we
haven't even begun to turn that valve on
we could charge them interest we have
all these optional other revenue streams
that we have kind of in the wings that
if we want to we can do we don't even
think we'll need to and
contests ready content yeah it's a
vehicle oh you know so they won the
second prize the members project or the
best well run contest out there just
project
we've Google tuned to the hundred there
at that project their cake away ten
million dollars you go there at this
month with your little project and it's
funny because we thought from the
beginning I had worked my profits before
really only non profits for school and
it was like we don't spend all our time
fundraising so we didn't want to do
unless we could build on the revenue
streams and additionally we're gonna say
about this oh this is crazy this is all
another whole conversation but we're
more profitable as a nonprofit than its
a for-profit because our business model
includes all this subs all these
subsidies from like PayPal early on
we're like PayPal this is another part
to PayPal would you please wave all our
transaction fees that would be so
awesome they've never done it for any
other organization before but they did
it for us that saves to three percent on
the 56 million dollars that's gone back
and forth like huge for our business
model we could have been for-profit we
almost were poor profit we decided it
was better and we could do we wanted to
do this we didn't want to get rich we
wanted to do this and we knew that we
can do that and have a really good more
profitable model is a non-profit cuz of
all the goodwill and other stuff that
you get so I can't see me sorry Dana
sure sure
we are gonna this summer I think there's
a sweet spot here where it's enough it's
enough people can absorb it it's enough
to kind of get the idea of it you have
sort of a number of ways of absorbing
information you have the picture if the
narrative you have the bullet points
like name location business mountain
whatever below that as the story unfolds
you again have like bullet points of
repayment on the state da-da-da-da-da or
the journals
I think it's been adequate and actually
it's a very important like value for us
like being scrappy being iterative like
it's good enough throw it out there see
what happens add to it if you need to
this has been sufficient even though
there are a lot of other websites out
there giving websites all kinds of
websites that do they have something go
global giving it like every piece of
information you'd ever want and I know I
mean they're they're amazing but but
like I think too much information can be
really bad like I know for me for global
giving for a while and they've adjusted
a lot of different things you would see
projects there were $3,000 HG projects
that were three hundred thousand dollars
you'd see four tabs of information about
the project you'd see hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of projects on
every different topic like they are the
portal and they're the leaders and
that's like they did it first like a big
project base giving site but for me I
get a little lost in it we have our
fellows that are they have all flip
videos and stuff like that and they have
a great the fellows blog is really
interesting too because they're each
their own champion lenders can be their
own champions as Kiva everyone has their
own little place to expand and put more
detail if they want and you can go find
that pretty easily but we're gonna see
another
yeah so we just basically have armed our
fellows you know in any given time we
have a few dozen fellows out in the
field daily like adding more info from
businesses and stuff and we've given
them video cameras and they're just
gonna do I'm sure they're gonna like
blow our expectations like just do go
above and beyond and include really
interesting I think for better for worse
lenders would have all along the way it
would have been less willing and you
know we did in one survey like two years
ago say hey if we were for profit would
that change how you interact with us and
a lot a lot would have dropped off now
we think it's like a tax code not a
religion you can still do the exact same
stuff and it's just what happens with
your profit you know you can do the same
thing in the world but I think yes
there's this spirit of trust and oh I
get what your intentions are because
you're nonprofit it's so clear we wanted
to just keep it that way when you check
out you see and there's like a you know
you set you check a box says I've read
this and I understand I'm taking on
DeForest I understand this isn't tax
deductible like we give him the
information right before they check out
but yeah up until that point of the
transaction I really I mean we would
tell them we wouldn't go do this in a
sneaky way and I don't think we'll ever
do it I hope we don't ever do it because
I don't think it's necessary but yeah I
think you couldn't tell you probably
couldn't tell in a lot of ways if we in
the back end made that switch
okay we go in the forum line of classes
so no I'm sorry all right well I will
always try again at 11:30 we choose
another Oh forgive me for going over
this time so Kathleen extremer research
with another individual can think of us
and what we do is we manipulate whether
people are introduced to organizations
as a diet or that person sitcom what we
find is two or three effects of really
interesting first Donna works by highly
associated being more inspirational
engaging people want to work there they
are seen as totally needy people do not
want to buy products there this is yeah
yeah when you say well good is it you
and you when you teach people about
effective profitable and so like cold
only about money a guy so what's
happening is that people stereotype if
you will these two types of
organizational structures I'm not
realizing for us that you know warmth
and confidence or two dimensions
that are you can on this space being
highly effective but also inspirational
and I think that that's what you're
seeing in Cuba but you need to have
those measures in there you need to have
the science behind they're bigger behind
the business revenues for the long haul
for people to understand that as this
day you'll be carrying from coke lab
later on hope that was actually based on
our research going to come up with this
is the remission video shooting a DVD
game turned into kids with cancer it's
actually kind of like a for-profit arm
because of this very problem when people
start to learn more there's a whole set
of Association do you see social
enterprise you see the nature of this
this class is about you know busting
through those stereotypes to create new
business models that let the fact that
you can be effective in an incredible
way but also the inspirational vanity
the remarkable work of the bra Obama
campaign and I think you see also there
something that could be both inspired as
well as a truly effective so throughout
the class
this unit research on something more
ambiguous like a dotnet which is used by
both nonprofits and for-profits and
focus more like the content of the
actual if blogs count is that do you
think blogs coming up yeah so we have we
launched two features about I guess it's
like four or five months ago at this
point maybe six at the same time that
had a really we last night at like 1:00
a.m. I went to the site and I saw this
this happens sometimes
and this is a good thing we run out of
clothes this has been the mode of
operation for us for a half half of the
time in 2007 we needed to like cap low
and volume at $25 because you have too
much traffic and then we direct people
are very simple other actions but anyway
we where we build tools well the two
features we launched to work group
lending so you can lend in teams and
then also we did this liquidation of
partial credits so basically instead of
the fuel in twenty five dollars over a
nine month loan term before you would
have to wait until all those little bits
came back you'd know they were coming
back but only at the 9-month point could
you access your money and then real and
now it's like your dollar twenty five
comes back if you want to top that up in
real and today you can and we give it to
you right away which took money out of
our accounts which took away from the
float revenue stream anyway our point is
to keep it sticky and active and have
people lend so we have these features
that encourage people to lend in new
ways and be their own kind of champions
and take it upon themselves to like do a
group lending project for this wedding
or this birthday party or this team or
company or school whatever but
additionally we just have very basic
tools really none of them rocket learns
to allow people to spread the word
really easily so as soon as you click
you know done with my pay
or something in paypal or whatever the
next screen you see is hey take 30
seconds and send an email to a friend of
yours to also lend to this business
right now we do that we have all these
other tools for people to share and we
have lenders that do they are ahead of
us they go above and beyond and create
things that we're like that's a really
good idea so there's I've one other
screen shot I really need to show you um
there yeah great gegege great so keep a
PDF this is one of many sites that
people created our staff did not create
this we and and if you look on the side
Kiva links Kiva Kiva friends keep in my
space
somebody wrote to us one day and they're
like oh good news I got a really good
office space for Cubans second life
we're having a welcoming an office
korean party next week you should all
stop by and really okay thank you so
lenders go do this and I think it's cuz
we're open with our brand and we say
take a look do you're gonna do have a
fun party like the Adrian granny it's so
funny he we like learn about it but
night it was happening really dude
people do things because they love it
and they can feel ownership and do it
themselves there's qtv 24/7 you can go
watch like videos about Kiva you want to
keep a podcast keep a store
someone else did the keep store and said
we should make t-shirts with keep its
logo and tote bags and stuff our lenders
just go do this I think it's because
they're in love I think it's because
they love it and we certainly don't lock
up our brand and our materials we spread
them out we have discussion boards we
say what do you think use this use this
so we empower our lenders we encourage
them and we say go team
it's like art right you look at it and
you decide what you think it is and then
run with it we're not we're not trying
to own it too closely we think it's a
movement that everyone can kind of
define and do what they want with